[Music]
just fifty two days until Megan and
Harry say I do and in tonight's Royal
report we've got new details on the
bridal party yeah keV we now know who
Megan and Harry will surround themselves
with on their big day starting with of
course Prince George and Princess
Charlotte will be a big part of the
royal wedding in May a source confirms
two et Harry's adorable nephew and niece
will act as beach boy and flower girl
other possible flower girls include
close friend Bonita lits daughters who
Megan has referred to as her fairy
goddaughter 'z day to be the adventure
of a lifetime
we're told just like William and Kate's
wedding it's expected that Megan and
Harry will have a mix of children from
their friends relatives and staff that
includes Emily Henson the little girl
who got caught stealing Harry's popcorn
at the Invictus games her dad is close
friends as for who Megan will entrust
maid of honor duties to her BFF from
Northwestern University TV producer
Lindsay Roth is the front runner Megan
was her lady-in-waiting at her 2016
wedding another possible attendant
Canadian stylist and close friend
Jessica Mulrooney who our source reveals
is helping Megan with her dress and
other elements of the wedding meanwhile
Harry's got Big Brother William to stand
by him as best man on his big day we're
told the groom-to-be has several close
childhood friends who all could serve as
Oscars among them mark Dyer who is like
a second father to Harry and acted as
his mentor after Diana's passing but the
Royal Wedding would not be complete
without this man Marcus Anderson who's
been a close friend of the couple's
since their early courtship we're told
he could have a significant role in the
ceremony perhaps doing reading
[Music]